Eric there is a exploit already out for
incursion specifically the Falcon Lost
mission and it's by using the
deployables cover or a ballistic shield
and you're basically cheating your way
into that big room yep basically you're
gonna make your way past these first
couple guys run all the way until you
get close to the start of the mission
and you're pretty much gonna use the
deploy will cover to you know face
through the walls something that's been
kind of being done already and then what
the ballistic shields it's a little bit
different and you need two people with
the shields and you kind of just keep
ramming into each other until you kind
of push the other person in through the
wall so to speak right and you're kind
of using melee to to kind of like
further nudge them I guess yeah so in
like one case you you were able to push
me but you know if you don't have
someone to do this with you can just do
it with the deploy will cover you kind
of just have to sprint against this wall
and then I was just spamming the
deployable cover I don't have like a
definitive way of doing it but you can
see that you know you sprint you kind of
try to do the deployable cover and
eventually you're gonna face through the
wall and once you face to the wall it's
pretty interesting because the AI
doesn't like know you're there so we did
this on hardmode it took a while
I mean we're it's funny like we just
kind of wanted to talk about this
exploit whether it's worth it or not
it's kind of up in the air I think but
anyways what we had to do also was
basically beef up all of your
electronics yep you want to get your
skills up and you definitely want to
change your skills at this point once
you're in there you're gonna want the
sticky bomb with a bf be mod on it and
then we were using the support station
with the ammo cache perk because that
gets your skills back faster and so
basically you're spamming the sticky mod
on or below the APC until it eventually
dies yeah and it took us a while right
it took us about 45 maybe 30 minutes
we're hearing that some people were able
to do in 30 minutes when it comes down
to it you know this is a fairly
difficult mission I feel and when it
come when it comes down to like getting
a great team and if your matchmaking
that can take forever this exploit might
be useful yeah I think I had the scary
thing is that was only like 30 to 40
minutes for us
- right right like and we're not
properly tuned like I had more
electronics and more skill power than
you did so I was doing more damage also
elite damage does affect the APC so I
think with us a crew of four with the
right kind of modifiers on your armor
and a lot of skill power these this APC
could go down pretty quickly it's a it's
a lot harder and challenging mode
I've been semi soloing it and I've only
moved it down like four bars in like two
hours or something like that and that's
like doing 300,000 this is this is
currently what we're looking at this is
the challenge mode version yeah so yeah
and there's other ways as well to do
damage to the APC there's you can use
frag grenades which you discovered it
does at least for me was like 90,000
explosive rounds kind of works sort of
sort of and then you can also you know
drink water and/or soda to affect your
cool down and do elite damage yeah
eventually you're gonna run out of those
things but it'll help bring this dude
down yeah so you know you can get ready
to you know maybe have your Netflix on
one screen and then have this on the
other and you're just gonna kind of fire
off sticky mods every now and then but
hey you're gonna get set items and
they're for me today this morning I was
able to solo the hard mode and then I
did get the kind of like weekly here's a
reward for you know finishing the
incursion but when we did it together
you didn't get that unfortunately so I'm
not we're not too sure why that's the
case yeah it was kind of bummer yeah
take advantage of the exploit while you
can because you know polygons and it'll
be gone soon
well thanks Eric Thank You ruff
you